ja nicht so ein richtiges goodbye aber
als wird zwei wochen oder so denn meine
lieben freunde ich könnte mir eine pause
von youtube nicht von social media
generell auf instagram werde ich
weiterhin aktiv sein ich hätte dort
bilder posten stories posten dann könnt
ihr auch sehen was bei mir ab geht in
den nächsten zwei wochen ich werde auch
auf tik tok aktiver sein dort habe ich
mir vorgenommen jeden zweiten dritten
tag neues video zu laden also eigentlich
wird das gar keine pause sondern ich
höre nur kurz oft mit youtube-videos
aber warum überhaupt luca dem ich vor
sechs jahren nach meinem abitur hier
nach köln gezogen bin um zu studieren
habe ich nahezu täglich ein video
hochgeladen und diese videos habe ich
alle selber aufgenommen mir selber die
ideen überlegt und auch selber
geschnitten und das ist eine menge
arbeit
ich weiß viele leute sehen youtube nicht
so richtig als job an aber es ist
wirklich arbeit auch wenn man es
teilweise nicht direkt sieht in den
letzten jahren habe ich natürlich ab und
zu auch urlaub gemacht mal irgendwie für
eine woche amerika oder mal für zwei
wochen eine nordsee oder so allerdings
war die zeit vor dem urlaub immer der
doppelte stress bei mir weil ich dann
halt jeden tag zwei videos gemacht habe
stellt euch vor ich für eine woche in
den urlaub und da sollen trotzdem
täglich videos kommen das heißt die
woche davor muss ich jeden tag zwei
videos machen um einmal diese woche hier
mit videos zu füllen und auch noch diese
hier das heißt das doppelte an videos
pro woche doppelter stress dann im
urlaub gar kein stress ist es dann auch
nicht gesund für den körper und jetzt
habe ich mir einfach gesagt hey luca ab
heute bis sie an der nordsee für
anderthalb bis zwei wochen könnte doch
einfach mal pause nichts mit videos
vorproduzieren für die zeit nicht laptop
mitnehmen und videos dort schneiden
sondern wirklich einfach zeit für mich
nehmen zeit mit meinen freunden
verbringen zeit auch für mich alleine
dort irgendwie ich habe
strandspaziergängen plan ich bin fast
1000 machen lassen
geht bei mir einfach gerade so viel ab
im leben das ich in meinem kopf nicht
für jedes einzelne thema was bei mir
doch aktuell ist den platz habe
beziehungsweise die aufmerksamkeit
diesem thema geben kann wie es gern
machen möchte und das habt ihr auch
einmal im content in den letzten wochen
gemerkt dass waren vermehrt videos dabei
wo ich mir selber im schnitt gedacht
habe hey wir nicht das wirkliche
hochladen aber ich brauche noch ein
video und da konnte ich auch nichts
neues mehr aufnehmen weil dann hatte ich
wieder ein telefonat weil irgendwas in
hamburg mit der wohnung die ich gerade
bauer nicht geklappt haben das war ein
fast und stress das waren ganz viele
kopfschmerzen die ich hatte
und ich war nicht happy mit youtube mit
meinen videos und jetzt habe ich mir
gesagt komm ich mache mal zwei wochen
pause ich nehme zwar eine kamera mit
also ich werde auch sachen im urlaub
filmen allerdings wenn ich danach
zurückkommen bin ich hoffentlich frei
ich habe genug geschlafen ich habe
urlaub gemacht habe komplett
abgeschaltet und kann wieder frisch
durchstarten mit videos und will dann
noch anfangen mit blogs in hamburg und
wird auch so ein bisschen meinen kanal
konzept wieder umdenken das mache ich ja
alle paar monate jahre im all den
letzten wochen habe ich mich dann auch
vermehrt nach einem cutter umgesehen der
dadurch das hat meine videos schneidet
wir nochmal zeit sparen würde und
mittlerweile kenne ich keinen großen
deutschen youtuber der seine videos noch
selber schneidet außer mich deswegen
wäre das auch für mich mittlerweile ein
thema wo ich sagen würde haye um ihre
arbeit abzunehmen und um auf meinen
körper zu hören und mehr zeit selber zu
verbringen und mit meiner gesundheit ist
das auf jeden fall der richtige weg
allerdings habe ich keinen richtigen
gefunden der den stil so trifft wie ich
gerne haben möchte also das ist glaube
ich auch noch mal ein längerer prozess
den ich dadurch laufen muss allerdings
wollte ich dann halt auch nicht videos
raushauen mit denen ich nur zu 50
prozent zufrieden bin
deswegen dachte ich mir jetzt für die
zeit hierfür die zwei wochen ich gönne
mir wirklich komplett pause ich will
mich auch überhaupt nicht über meinen
beruf hier beschweren über youtube
social media um gottes willen ich bin
total froh dass ich das ganze ausleben
möchte darf dabei allerdings ist social
media hat ein ständiger kopfing
und das ist noch viel krasser wenn man
das ganze zeit beruflich macht und
ständig an zahlen et cetera denkt
während der korona zeit also wegen
während der krassen corona zeit
irgendwann im februar märz april oder so
habe ich ja mit meinem hauptkanal und 2
kanal jeden tag ein video hochgeladen
und hatte da teilweise monatlich 70
millionen views was die meisten views
waren in ganz deutschland die einen
youtube kanal in der zeit da gemacht hat
und da habe ich richtig heftig
durchgezogen dagegen allerdings auch
nichts ab in meinem leben also der umzug
nach hamburg wird es also der
wohnungsbau komplett gestoppt da ging
nichts weiter wegen corona ich konnte
nicht raus wegen corona nichts mit
freunden machen ich hatte keine termine
mehr da war youtube für mich halt
einfach in zehn stunden job jetzt ist
eine menge los in meinem leben es ist
sommer und freunde von mir sind auch
draußen unterwegs und ich möchte einfach
da gerade ein bisschen zeit rein
investieren in diese ganzen anderen
baustellen die ich gerade meinen kopf
habe das unter anderem auch mein körper
ist meine gesundheit und da möchte ich
einfach drauf hören
deswegen sage ich tschüss für zwei
wochen das ist das was sie quasi wissen
müsst ich bin für zwei wochen jetzt weg
von youtube nicht von tik tok instagram
et cetera so folgt mir dort gerne da
werde ich weiterhin aktiv sein und dann
sehen wir uns in zwei wochen wieder
ich habe euch lieb und danke für euren
langjährigen support und ich hoffe wir
sehen uns dann auch wieder und die
bleibtreu abonnent und luca view